مثلاً، إذا فيه خالاتي يجلسون يتكلمون عن الألوان
تطلع مصطلحات غريبة
تفاحي، تركوازي
ما أدري أيش، تركستاني
أنا عبدالرحمن عبدالكريم الشبنان
أنا طالب طب، سنة رابعة
ممكن كثير من الناس عندهم تعريف خاطئ له
أن المصاب بعمى الألوان خلاص يشوف أبيض وأسود
عمى الألوان فيه أكثر من نوع
فيه عمى الألوان للون الأخضر
فيه عمى ألوان للون الأحمر، وفيه للأزرق
مثلًا فيه واحد يلعب في كأس المدرسة
أقول والله اللي لابس أخضر يعرف يلعب
يقولون ما فيه أحد لابس أخضر؟ وين؟
أيش تشوف؟
خلاص، ما صرت أوصف لون
أقول هذا الطويل يعرف يلعب
ما أقول اللي لابس أخضر
فأنا اللي فيني عمى أخضر
تحط لي لون بني
جنب لون أخضر
جنب لون أخضر غامق
هنا ما بقدر أفرق بين الثلاثة
«متى اكتشفت إصابتك بعمى الألوان؟»
كان مجلس مع أمي، وبدأوا يتكلمون عن الألوان
ويؤشرون على الأشياء
ويسألوني هذا أيش تشوفه؟
والله أنا أشوفه بني
يناظرون فيني
طيب هذا أيش تشوفه؟
طلعت ثلاثة أربعة أشياء غلط، أوصفها غلط
نفس ذاك اليوم سويت الاختبار
جبت أخواني، سوّوا الاختبار
دخلت عليهم بعد ما اكتشفت أنه فيني
قال لي صديقي روح لعيال خالتك
تسعين بالمئة بتلقى عندهم عمى ألوان
رحت لهم فعلًا
دخلت عليهم، قلت لهم سوّوا هذا الاختبار
ما في أرقام، ما يشوفون أرقام زيي
نسبة خمسة وتسعين بالمئة أو أكثر من الوالد
بس أنها هي اللي ورثته
وأبد، ورثت عيالها كلهم هي وأخواتها
«هل واجهت صعوبات في اختيار مجالك المهني؟»
بالنسبة لي، مو شيء معيق جدًا
غيري ممكن يشوفه شي معيق أكثر
مثلًا واحد من أيام المتوسط من أيام الثانوي
حلمه أنه يكون طيار حربي
فجأة تفاجأ أنه ما يقدر يدخل طيران حربي بسبب هذا الشيء
ممكن يشوفه شيء دمر حياته
لكن بالنسبة لي أنا
التخصص اللي كنت أبغاه من زمان هو الطب
وما كان يطلب عمى ألوان
فيه تخصصات داخل الطب
زي مثلًا طب الجلدية وطب العيون
هذه ممكن اللي عنده عمى ألوان
صعب عليه يدرسها
وصعب عليه أنه يمارسها أو يتخصص فيها
«كيف يتفاعل الناس عند ذكرك عمى ألوان؟»
زملائي مثلًا في الطب يعرفون أيش عمى الألوان
ويعرفون أن لها أنواع
إذا قلت لأحد فيهم تكون ردة فعله شوي حلوة
غير عن أحد مثلًا، في مجلس
في مكان ما أعرفه مثلًا
يعرف أن عندي عمى ألوان، ردة فعله تكون غريبة
«أيش هذا عمى الألوان؟»
ويبدأ يستلمني، يحط لك خمسة أشياء
يلا هذا أيش لونه، وهذا أيش لونه
واذا ماعرفت يبدأ، ليش ما تعرف
ليش ما تشوف؟
طيب، وريني الاختبار
يمكن يطلع فيني أنا بعد عمى ألوان
أول ماعرفت كنت متحمس أقول للناس عنه
لكن الحين يطفى الحماس
أي واحد يسأل، أقول عمى ألوان وفيه ثلاث أنواع
أخضر وأحمر وأزرق
وأنا فيني أخضر وخلاص
«هل تختلف إعدادات شاشات أجهزة المصاب بعمى الألوان»
في الجوال فيه، أغلب الألعاب
عندها في الإعدادات خيار للمصابين بعمى ألوان
أقرب مثال لعبة «كول أوف دوتي»
كان فيه المحادثة اللي تحت اليمين
أقدر أختار حق الفريق حقي بس
محادثة خاصّة مع اللي ضدي، واللي معاي كلهم
وما كنت أقدر أفرق باللون
ولما فعّلت خيار عمى ألوان
بدأ يوضح لي أكثر
لأن مخلين حق الفريق لحاله أخضر
ومخلين حق اللي ضدك برتقالي
وكان فيه صعوبة أني أفرق بينهم
أن هذا يكلمني ولا يكلم اللي معاه؟
هذا يكلمني ولا يكلم أصدقائي
«هل تواجه مشكلات في تنسيق الملابس؟»
مرة لبست لبس، أنا اخترته بنفسي
ورحت فيه لأمي
وضحكت
وتناظرني من فوق إلى تحت
تقول لي أيش هذا؟ تداخل الألوان غير طبيعي
يعني من بعد ذاك الموقف
تقريبًا قل اعتمادي على نفسي بالملابس أكثر
صارت الوالدة هي اللي تشتري لي أكثر
إذا أبغى أشتري لنفسي، محدود تقريبًا في الألوان
اللي هي أبيض وأسود
أشياء أضمن نفسي فيها
«متى يكون عمى الألوان عائق لك؟»
حصة الفنية كانت أسوأ حصة عندي في المدرسة
أولًا لأني ما أعرف أرسم
ثانيًا لأن إذا رسمت ما أعرف ألوّن
يمكن فيه مدرسين فهموا الموضوع
عرفوا أن عندي صعوبة مع الرسم
خلاص صار ما يشد علي
لكن فيه مدرسين ثانيين يشدون
كانت فيه صعوبات
كنت أكره الحصة بكبرها
«هل أثّر فيك عمى الألوان؟»
كانت تسبب لي إحباط
أن اللون هذا ما أقدر أشوفه
أو عندي مشكلة معاه وباقي الناس يقدرون يصفّونه
ويتكلمون عنه بشكل عادي
مثل ما قلت
أن المشكلة داخلية أكثر من أنها تظهر للناس
داخل نفسي أقول ليش ما أشوف مثل باقي الناس
ليش بالذات اللون هذا ما أقدر أشوفه؟
ليش باقي الألوان عادي؟
«كيف تصف شعورك بعد تجربة عدسة تصحيح الألوان؟»
كان شعور..
كانت العدسة كذا، وأنزلها ما في رقم
وأرفعها فيه رقم
كان شعور شوي حلو وشوي مو حلو في نفس الوقت
ليش ما أقدر أشوفها بدون العدسة؟
أنا اللي عندي حاليًا شديد
الاختبار تقريبًا جبت فيه 2 من 17
يعني قدرت أشوف رقمين داخل الدوائر
من 17 رقم، ويعتبر شيء شديد
فيه رقم أصلًا؟
هذه ثلاثة
لا
صح، إلّا ثلاثة
أنت وين؟
ثمانية
صح؟
نبغاك تصفق بس، عشان نربط الصوت مع الصورة
عطينا صفقة